I
you
cool so this is matt from NMR i'm here
with guys from booyah pictures uh
introduce yourselves hey i'm ryan also
known as Papa pre and i'm the producer
i'm charles also knows is Chuck and I'm
the dep director co-director and that
sexy accent is from France I'm uh I'm
Ryan coopersmith and I'm the director
writer and actor extraordinaire right on
so you guys just did like four parodies
in a row of that movie VHS um so my
question to you is would you guys rather
have a ghost for a roommate or have to
sleep in a sealed coffin every night oh
that's a good one um one kind of ghost
like a sexy ghosts are like a haunting
ghost that's gonna scare you I could it
just yeah yeah can we touch the ghost um
you can't touch the ghost but the ghost
can touch you and it's like Casper so
it's a little boy ghost-like devon Sawa
little boy I don't know who that is guy
said that's Casper devon Sawa is that
his name yeah that's the actor hahaha i
would take devon Sawa you would take the
ghost remain I take bill pullman Bill
Pullman okay and you mmm I think I go
with the ghost also okay so no one will
go with this next upcoming but now but
what else spoon with each other so we
wouldn't sleep well in a costume uh but
what if the ghosts like ghosts don't
sleep so would keep you up like it
whining all night and bitching about
being dead no neither do we anything he
owes every week we don't sleep I feel
like we're ghosts so you guys have the
grandma reads tweets you know you guys
usually do that you to 50 cent you did
odd future in that same vein would you
guys rather bathe with your grandparents
for every single shower or be sexually
attracted to nothing but birds oh sorry
Z question trick question no my grandpa
is gonna look like birds so I don't know
if it'll be different um what is it it's
sleeping with your grandparents or
sexually being like
you bathed with your grandparents so you
would take nothing but showers and baths
ism for every time you showered or you
would only be sexually attracted to
birds all right again on this specific
if your grandparents are dead you get to
like bait with corpse or it's like
fictional grandparents um they would be
replaced by actors who were the same age
as your grandparents would be if they
were alive I'll take the word yeah
especially pelicans especially pelicans
and got big mouths I think birds too
yessir i'm sure i pay that my
grandparents louis at some age and I got
a trophy over snoots yeah you want to
try anything haha have you ever asked
and we out like caught your grandmother
in the shower have I yeah oh god no
never I wouldn't be I wouldn't be alive
right now would just kill yourself a
media yes sir that's neither ya know
does that's not yeah that's where all
this maybe that's where all this deep
humor came from that hunting moments
when we all saw her grandmother naked in
the shower Lucia equally justice served
us chicken soup Norwich hard but I'm not
most probably watching this so we didn't
we don't never happened and we don't
remember it or not scarred from the
career path that you chose has nothing
to do with that at all no so so you guys
just collaborated with Epic Meal Time
and you guys would collaborate with him
a lot you guys just did something for
them and then they did something for you
guys with Epic Meal Time stole my
girlfriend if you had to fight any
member of Epic Meal Time which one would
you fight fistfight not let me know
because that guy's got weapons yeah yo
that's that's crazy good because there's
a question they're so big and we're so
small every time we get in that office
there they're like seven foot tall and
we're skinny dudes this is the this is
actually a true story every time we go
into their office I don't think any time
goes by without Chuck and Harley getting
into like a savage fistfight and slap
fight of some sort but he's so strong I
mean I'm quick and he's slow and fat but
he's strong so I don't know that should
be it
thank you its own youtube series youtube
celebrity deathmatch I think I think the
dudes from Epic Meal Time would win the
championship week we just they were
doing something in LA and we just
interview them and I thought like they
were just big on camera I didn't think
they were that bad they're not a huge
there enjoy Norma's that's like there's
even if there weren't celebrities or I
mean known on the like yeah even if they
were known they'd still you you could
still see them coming you're so tall so
if I had to take a punch to the face
from any of them guess it'd be Tyler
Tycho yeah Tycho cuz he's the sweetest
yeah oh yeah he was a really cool to
surprise but after I was surprised to
learn that he didn't he didn't like
hockey that much what about you guys you
bummed about the lockout yeah yeah this
guy this guy doesn't know anything but
those two guys here crying every night
this sucks worried cuz they really serve
like amazing hot dogs at the stadium no
no cuz the house have the best team this
season ugm you coach p que suba and we
have a great team and we can play yes
which sucks yeah it didn't buy a pair we
play a lot of this oh h what isn't there
13 so vital what so did you guys like
three years behind on that that's crazy
so trying to figure out the controls um
you guys just signed to the collective
right yeah why'd you guys sign at the
collective um I guess they were the only
ones nice enough to uh to love us yeah I
mean cuz they're so nice like but like
there's some of I guess from the
beginning to give us a shot they said
you know what we like what you guys
doing you don't get many views but we
love your content and eventually maybe
by working together we can grow your
views and and also we love like some
some people at the collective do great
things and and that's why i also like
VHS was cool because there's people from
the collective but we got to spoke to
the producer and like that's that's
crazy that's a film i've been pumped up
for like a year now people cool would
you guys rather have a shark bite off
your
firm your leg or your dick well oh
that's the logic no all agree hump that
well if they bit off your dick where do
you like you have to get like an you
let's say bigger dick uh no ha it would
be robotic grow by winning in the oceans
and I guess stick two daughters and then
like uh oh my god as it is if it's your
arm is that your arm they do everything
with or the arm that you don't do
everything the one you don't do
everything with so if you're
right-handed it's your left arm okay so
it's not your masturbating and I'm the
dexterous uh I guess I are my leg so
that we can still edit these weekly
videos yeah I lose my arm yeah I'd like
to be the one arm man yeah I this my
arms so we can still run thick here all
right so someone offers you ten thousand
dollars but you have to be in an animal
porn would you be in it Wow pralaya
eleven eleven thousand and you go to do
10,000 I don't know what that is and
what do you guys loonies and toonies
right yeah any yet we walk around with
socks a change with sacks of coins yeah
wait what was the question again huh sex
with animal oh yeah having sex with
animals I feel like God bestiality might
be than you like bisexual bisexual thing
going on you know and maybe like in the
next few years that'll be a little less
i do do we actually just watched a
documentary on some South American
country where they have sex with the
boys have sex with camels or don't know
donkeys donkey so that's absolutely epic
illness yeah yeah I'm sure as you praise
this video that's what happens when you
go to their office see there you see
little boy sex with donkeys Matthew yeah
oh yeah oh so I'm answer your question
um yeah
so you do for ten thousand I like we
already deal that we have sex with birds
so now you're just paying us for it
right that's true well yeah yeah you're
right well they exist in different
worlds it's some realities where we keep
at it I love the dark tower I
love how these are questions I like
gonna be the questions we got for the
rest of our career huh you have sex with
the dude if this was an Oprah interview
the questions would be the same looks
dish because it's us you just have to
start with crazy though well I feel like
if i asked you guys just like questions
about being on YouTube man it's so
boring no like no the research you guys
questions in the world don't get it
second standards high for a future
interviews all right so you guys are
stuck on a desert island right yeah you
can only take one movie but it has to
have Denzel Washington in it what movie
would it be there's one right here that
says it that doesn't dental hush as Al
Pacino Denzel Washington yo I would
think that I would either take that
movie where he plays you know that guy
that chased that d diamond that changes
body John Key oh no no like it's a movie
with John Goodman and then to Washington
one raining day wouldn't and yeah what
is it what is that movie where he'll
like the devil's advocate is as Al
Pacino now I know you're but its origins
change the question temperature I would
take training days training day okay
training day I'm a Disney fan so I
remember the tysons oh it's a good one
i'm going to i go out on a guess and say
the upcoming flight oh no flight imani
lou has been the gambler that's a
controversial choice what if it's shitty
well I guess I'm already on a deserted
island so I was probably already in a
plane crash and they could probably just
relate to it flipped our plan
yeah Oh car buying a drum um if you guys
weren't on YouTube what would you be
doing accountants making movies for our
family and friends I'm filming bar
mitzvahs are low all right so this is
the next segment I have planned it's a
complete test segment so I'm hoping it's
gonna work okay but basically yeah
you've been frozen in the most serious
position this interview so ok I'm going
to 10 second word association so I'm
gonna get give you guys 10 seconds each
you tell me the word that you think of
after I say a word okay okay all right
Ryan are you ready ready all right let
me get my timer here hold on yes my
timer okay okay uh all right we're
starting now beard fish oil
wait this is still me yeah yeah toe gets
a fish a mousetrap fury Nick
sparkles a cute little kitten read what
red blood jerk jerk jerk uh chicken box
um Charles all right that was your 10
seconds all right moving to you thank
you I'm a quick thinker all right you
ready I think the middle gyros that's
right gentle okay ready I he's also i
got ya i might need translation and
every we're gonna answer in French okay
can't you go ahead and answer in French
I'm title it however you want okay you
ready yeah okay horses ah so very can't
or a unicorn yeah you know it's not my
life it takes me forever unicorn done
okay James Franco James Bond alphabet
alphabet yeah suit Canada
uh horses bush george island island yep
lost vitamin uh like someone strong like
Schwarzenegger ok Oprah Winfrey yeah
that's very weak I'm just completing a
star um like for Lexie like milky way uh
and finally David Bowie oh love okay
sick there you go be cool there you go
that was your 10 seconds all right
wrapping it up you're coming around the
horns okay you ready danker take it all
the way pop free take it away all right
come spoon sushi this guy's quick uh
tuna weasel and check pirate eye patch
uh orphan uh this guy raywilliamjohnson
a football until you keep asking those
questions will discover the meaning of
life yeah you can tell that we're a
great improv all right three more
barbecue sausage mustache mustache man
techno sorry techno regnant um deadmau5
all right there we go guys we did it
with real quick on our unit as Canadians
like it was it was an experimental uh
you know segue an experimental segment
and the internet was terrible so we'll
just caught we'll chalk it up to the
hurricane the internet and shark attacks
haha sounds amazing thanks a lot we love
you yeah and it's again no no no
we're good we're good okay sorry you're
frozen again very serious blows I'm oh
frozen that maybe I'm just doing that on
purpose like I'm mining for you guys so
I'm frozen now right ok just ya i will
cool guys thanks so much for talking me
I appreciate it I've awesome thank you
very much thanks a lot i do right take
it easy guys you do all right i love you
we love you oh hey i love you too
you